[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi racconto perché in belgio
ho deciso di cercare le madri dei miei
rapitori
sei anni fa sono stata sequestrata in
siria mentre lavoravo con una troupe
della rai e durante questo sequestro
ho avuto modo di riconoscere il gruppo
che ci aveva arrestato
questo gruppo che io avevo già di cui
avevo già parlato nei miei servizi aveva
un nome già pad alnus tra che significa
a fronte di liberazione del popolo
poi si sono sciolti nel isis ma durante
le ore delle prime ore del mio sequestro
ho pensato a questo nome
zapata illustra fronte di liberazione
del popolo liberazione già ma da che
cosa forse liberazione dalla libertà
almeno questo è quello che ho
sperimentato io durante la mia prigionia
sono stata tenuta in isolamento coperta
letteralmente coperta da una coperta
perché non avevo un burqa quindi dovevo
essere relegata lì ma non ero sola era
un isolamento ma non ero sola c'erano i
miliziani armati che mi vigilavano un
giorno e notte erano uomini sono stata
anche con una donna
la mia carriera e ho imparato poi a
distinguerli in base alle lingue che
parlavano e ai dialetti a chi erano
questi miliziani
alcuni erano francofoni questo significa
che potevano venire tanto dalla tunisia
quanto dalla francia dal belgio
così quando nel 1200 mila e 18
mi sono trasferita a bruxelles ho
pensato che era arrivato il momento di
andare a scoprire chi erano le madri di
questi forum fighters un dialogo un
incontro che per me
significava moltissimo significava
innanzitutto riconciliarmi con
quell'esperienza tremenda che è stata
per me la privazione della libertà ma è
stato anche poi scoprire capire se è
giusto o sbagliato attribuire alle madri
sempre l'origine di tutte le colpe ho
incontrato due donne la prima si chiama
sale a ben ali ed è una donna
estremamente forte che ama il belgio per
che le ha permesso di crescere in una
cultura libera e non patriarcale ti amo
ha le sue leggi
ama la libertà di espressione e la
differenza la tolleranza tutti questi
sono principi che lei ha assorbito e poi
ha trasmesso al figlio io ho letto la
sua biografia e ho avuto l'impressione
di essere ritornata al liceo quando
leggevo le tragedie greche
lei sembra l'eroe di una tragedia greca
cerca di ribellarsi a un destino
inesorabile
ho fatto un maligno perché fa tutto
giusto e poi diventa tutto sbagliato
tutte le scelte che le fa con questo
figlio sabri che a 18 anni dopo aver
ricevuto il lavaggio del cervello da una
organizzazione apparentemente di
beneficenza che si chiamava sharia for
belgio decide di partire ovviamente non
è una decisione così che è avvenuta da
un giorno alla notte ci sono stati mesi
di radicalizzazione in cui lei stava
vicino al figlio per monitorarlo ma poi
la decisione che si è avvenuta dal
giorno alla notte è stata quella di
partire perché a un certo punto sempre
stato così intelligente da dissimulare
far credere alla mamma che s'era
rinsavito quindi lei ha mollato la presa
addirittura arrivata era arrivata al
punto di non permettergli più di uscire
di casa ma poi quando ha visto che
figlio sia rinsavito dopo una bellissima
vacanza trascorsa insieme in marocco
sulle spiagge a fare cose che nella sua
nuova visione dell'islam proibitivo
erano pezzi
ha pensato a mio figlio a 18 anni può
sbagliare e può cambiare idea
in fondo chi è mio figlio e quel bambino
giocherellone che mi tirava la gonna è
quel bambino che a basket proteggeva ai
bambini più deboli dai bulli
questo è mio figlio e questo è tornato
un figlio una mattina si sveglia e trova
la stanza di sapri vuota capisce
immediatamente quello che è successo
chiama la polizia
per farlo arrestare ma la polizia non
arresta un diciottenne che viaggia da
solo e libero anche se questo
diciottenne fino al giorno prima non
sapeva rifarsi il letto però un neo
maggiorenne salina ha vissuto questa
grande tragedia ma non è rimasta passiva
ha fondato un'associazione che si chiama
se il belgio è già dal nome fa capire
che non solo vuole aiutare le famiglie
che si trovano sua stessa condizione ma
vuole salvare una generazione di nuovi
potenziali fighters nella sua stessa
condizione si è trovata un'altra donna
che si chiama fatica questa donna non è
solo madre di forum fighters e nonna di
bambini innocenti bambini innocenti che
si trovano nel campo di alcol è un campo
di detenzione in una parte molto
desertica della siria al confine con
l'iraq ed è un campo molto discusso
perché ci si trovano le vedove del dash
dell'isis si spera o quantomeno gli
stati uniti stanno esortando le locali
forze locali di liberare questo campo ma
le cancellerie europee hanno l'obbligo
di riprendersi i loro cittadini ovvero
il forum fighters la maggior parte di
questi sono donne e sono bambini che
colpa hanno questi bambini
quando ho parlato con fatica che mi ha
fatto vedere le foto di questi bambini
che hanno un'età compresa tra l'uno ei 6
anni
alcuni sono biondi perché la moglie del
suo figlio è una ragazza delle fiandre
che si è convertita altri invece sono di
carnagione olivastra perché poi sia sua
figlia che la ruora se sono dovute
risposare quindi lì i matrimoni vengono
combinati all'ultimo minuto ecco ho
visto queste insieme di di bambini e ho
pensato che sono degli innocenti e che
meritano di tornare in belgio dalla
nonna fatica ha espresso il suo
cordoglio
davanti all immagine del figlio morto
nel computer
ho riflettuto sull'assurdità di un lutto
solo digitale
mentirei se vi dicessi che ho provato
compassione per la foto di quel ragazzo
morto per quel ragazzo morto dai capelli
spettinati le labbra violacee una ferita
pulita all'altezza del cuore e io non ho
provato nulla perché poteva essere uno
dei miei rapitori però mentirei se vi
dicessi che non ho provato compassione
per quella donna che piangeva
mentirei se vi dicessi che non mi sta a
cuore il destino dei figli di quel lou
reed in quel ragazzo che ha fatto la
ciad e che è morto
ora sono passati sei anni da quell
esperienza sono diventata madre era
giorno in modo diverso però già
all'epoca prima di sperimentare la
maternità biologica avevo già capito che
parte almeno buona parte delle madri i
tuoi foreign fighters non sa la stavano
passando bene
forse stavano vivendo la stessa angoscia
che viveva la mia di madre sapendo che
era in un paese in guerra come è
cambiata la mia vita ma innanzitutto
provo un grandissimo senso di
gratitudine per ogni giorno che passa è
come un dono non credo di avere dei
traumi ma provo un profondo bisogno di
capire qual è il comportamento dietro la
devianza cioè che cosa spinge una
persona a violare i diritti umani di
un'altra persona
ecco questo mi fa arrabbiare e non
avviene solo da parte dei criminali
quelli che noi chiamiamo terroristi
viene tutti i giorni quindi io mi
arrabbio davanti alle violazioni diritti
umani dei migranti dei minori non
accompagnati e delle persone che vengono
private della libertà di espressione
come è capitato a me ecco io nel mio
piccolo cosa posso fare
posso parlarne perché sono una
giornalista e quindi lo sto facendo qui
con voi perché sento il desiderio di
aiutare così come sono stata aiutata io
ad uscire fuori da quella caverna oscura
che sarebbe potuta diventare la mia vita
se fossi rimasta nelle mani dei miei
rapitori
grazie
[Applauso]